cave ou deux je vous en parlais en titre
la percée du vin jaune a commencé ce
week-end dans la petite commune de saint
lothain dans le jura on a percé le
premier tonneau de millésimes 98 après
six ans et trois mois de vieillissement
virgin est fiché et philippe fives et
c'est une histoire de terre de glaise la
rencontre d'un cépage le savagnin et
d'un terroir pour faire un bon vin jaune
tout commence ici le terroir
oui cette terre cette terre qui colle
aux pieds ce sont les marnes du jura
alors le sous sol est rempli de marne
bleus c'est la condition indispensable
pour espérer pouvoir faire un bon vin
jaune et vous le retrouvez que dans le
jura
bernard badoz vinifie du vin jaune
depuis 25 ans et pourtant il n'a
toujours pas percer son secret ce sont
aussi tard dans le monde du vin celui là
est une énigme qui commence en captivité
pendant six ans le breuvage est
emprisonné en fût de chêne le vigneron
le laisse ainsi se reposer et travailler
seul
le résultat est à la grâce des dieux on
essaie de comprendre mais il n'y a rien
à faire c'est le mystère des vins jaunes
pourquoi ce tonneau va bien évolué
pourquoi celui-ci ne va pas évoluer
on ne sait pas alors que toutes les
conditions sont réunies et c'est le même
produit
on n'a qu'une seule certitude ces quatre
sera pas le voile de levures là ya pas
de goût de vin jaune ça c'est sûr c'est
la seule certitude le reste l'alchimie
des levures qui se forme naturellement à
la surface du vent et que rien ne
trouble pas même le remplissage
car ici l'évaporation n'est pas compensé
un flux peut perdre jusqu'à un tiers de
sa capacité par rapport à l'eau on sait
que bientôt on pourra le mettre en
bouteille des bouteilles si particulière
de 62 centilitres qui scelle le mystère
120 jours
dans le vert enfin un coin du voile est
levé
on a une évolution sont les épices par
conséquent acté risée sur le côté un
petit peu noah curie gingembre très
épicé les épices douces
parmi les nombreux mystères du vin jaune
il en est un autre qui ne sera jamais
éclaircies celui de sa naissance
peut-être au xviiie siècle